of proposed federal ban on a potentially
deadly chemical found in common paint
strippers may be on hold indefinitely
the Environmental Protection Agency has
halted a proposed Obama era ban on
methylene chloride saying it needs more
time to consider still the agency has
said the chemical poses an unreasonable
risk it's been implicated in dozens of
deaths Anna Warner has been
investigating this story and only on CBS
this morning she spoke with the family
of one man whose recent death is linked
to this toxic chemical Anna good morning
good morning Nora it's another life lost
in an accident similar to the ones we've
heard before a young man using a paint
stripping product being overcome by
toxic fumes and dying and you may be
surprised to learn as this family was
that these cases go back decades pain
runs deep not only for me but my husband
and my other two sons
Cindy wins 31 year-old son Drew was the
youngest of her three sons an
entrepreneur with a cold brew coffee
business in Charleston South Carolina in
October he was resurfacing the floor of
this walk-in refrigerator using a paint
stripper goof-off manufactured by
company WM bar that's where his business
partner found him then called his
brother Clayton I said he's gone he's
gone I just screamed that over and over
again that's a phone call and over
forget the death certificate said he was
overcome by chemicals in the paint
stripper chief Lee highly toxic
methylene chloride it's deadly but found
in stripping products on store shelves
across the country something Drew's
brother Brian quickly learn I'm shocked
I mean how is it that you can find
something that will kill you instantly
and and buy it just off a shelf it's the
question we discovered another family
had asked some 20 years ago and this
hair was a product that Brian used
that's video of Pennsylvania's Wayne
Steiner from 1998 holding the can of
paint stripper that led to his son's
death you tell me how good this product
and why was Brian lied to get it and use
it 24 year-old Brian Keller had been
stripping paint off of a car using
another methylene chloride based product
clean strip air craft remover also made
by WM bar that he'd bought at a local
auto body shop then he fell ill I said
no I said he's going to the hospital I
said something's wrong not right medical
records show inhaling methylene chloride
vapors led to Keller having a heart
attack he survived in a weakened state
for five years until his mother Judy
says he had another heart attack I
thought this is it this is it
before his death Keller sued
manufacturer WM bar the company denied
responsibility in court filings saying
clean strips label warned the product
was for use by professional trained
personnel using proper equipment and is
not intended for sale to or use by the
general public
WM bar later settled the case for 1.75
million dollars without admitting
liability the family's attorney Marty
Brigham I really thought that this was a
problem that was behind us you did oh
absolutely and when I learned about the
accident with the same manufacturer 28
years later I was shocked not only that
but we found clean strip air craft paint
remover advertised for sale to the
public by numerous retailers including
Amazon I feel sorry because my parents
out there going through the same thing
this is just it should not be today's
society when they know that they know
that they know what this is doing I
don't get it the company declined to do
an on-camera interview but sent these
statements saying when used as directed
methylene chloride paint strippers have
an excellent safety record however they
said while we have always had a warning
on our label the recent tragedies have
motivated us to ask what more we can do
WM bar says it worked with the Consumer
Product Safety Commission on recently
issued guidelines to develop a new label
and warning symbol that are now
prominently featured on the front panels
of our methylene chloride products but
when the EPA moved last year to ban the
products it said revised labeling wasn't
enough that it will not address the
unreasonable risk presented by methylene
chloride drew wins brother Brian
couldn't agree more
my brother didn't need to die WM bar is
not the only manufacturer of paint
stripping products but it identifies
itself as the largest you can read the
statements the company sent us on our
website these products are already
banned in Europe and the winds aren't
waiting for the EPA action they're
launching a change.org petition to
pressure retail
to take methylene chloride based
products off store shelves we're gonna
try to start a movement the masks are
not enough for this stuff right you have
to have a specialty device that would
force oxygen into your face if you're
using it indoors and that is something
that the EPA says consumers are not
gonna buy it's like 500 bucks
especially equipment they don't
understand but the question is will the
EPA go through with the band they
proposed under the Obama administration
and environmental and consumer advocates
are very afraid that under the new Trump
administration that this is a move to
push this off push this off and just not
have it happen right and I wonder thanks
very much for being with us